[Musique]
bonsoir le début d'une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 bienvenue
dans cette édition du lundi 22 mars
voici les titres un nouveau confinement
étaient des marais a démarré samedi dans
toute l'ile-de-france pour quatre
semaines minimum pas d'attestation pour
les sorties proche de son domicile et
pas de durée limitée
résultat ce week-end les yvelinois été
nombreux à profiter du grand air
parmi les nouvelles mesures la fermeture
des commerces non essentiels même si les
dérogations sont nombreuses par rapport
aux deux derniers confinement c'est en
tout cas un énième moment délicat pour
les propriétaires des boutiques qui
doivent baisser de nouveau leur rideau
provisoirement et puis du 22 au 27 mars
et la semaine de la presse et des médias
dans l'école tv 78 est partenaire de
l'événement à cette occasion nous sommes
intervenus notamment à l'école
élémentaire and turgot à sartrouville
pour répondre aux nombreuses questions
des élèves et le printemps a démarré
officiellement ce week-end et depuis la
début mars est également le printemps
des poètes à 50 ans divine
l'événement se poursuit en ligne
jusqu'au 27 mars on en parle tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
depuis samedi les yvelines comme toute
l'île de france et huit autres
départements étaient placés en
confinement et ce pour quatre semaines
minimum l'attestation fait son retour
pour les déplacements à plus de dix
kilomètres de votre logement mais n'est
plus nécessaire dans ce périmètre avec
un justificatif de domicile
les sorties sont de plus ce ne sont plus
limités dans le temps et peuvent se
faire désormais jusqu'à 19 heures
horaires du couvre-feu la plupart des
yvelines ont donc profité du week-end et
des premiers rayons du soleil pour
réaliser des activités en extérieur le
reportage de mickaël millero pour ce
premier week-end de confinement les
yvelinois ont décidé de sortir tout en
respectant le rayon des 10 km imposées
par les autorités à plaisir ce dimanche
de nombreux promeneurs ont investi le
parc du château objectif s'offrir une
bouffée d'oxygène en famille ou entre
amis fait une petite balade pour
profiter un peu de l'ère des copines
bien sûr on a vu toutes les trois dans
le même immeuble donc ça pose aucun
problème
certains ont également profité de cette
sortie sans limitation de durée pour
faire un peu de sport une partie de
pétanque s'organise dans le parc
d'autres n'ont pas hésité à enfourcher
leur bicyclette à la je faire du vélo la
du vélo tout le long du parc là et puis
j'ai peut-être m'arrêter un petit peu
voilà prendre un peu le soleil un vu
qu'il est encore là
profiter un petit peu ça va faire du
bien j'ai besoin de verdure des espaces
de me balader 10 sport également à
voisins le bretonneux ce dimanche matin
des enfants font du roller dans cette
heure de jeu ici à 50 mètres cette
famille joue au rugby sur l'herbe depuis
plus d'une heure
sinon resteraient entre quatre murs dans
le salon on aura un peu en rond donc oui
nancy très bien de pouvoir s'aérer en
plus c'est pas mal d'espacés verts
autour de la maison
on en profite ici ça fait du bien malgré
le confinement way son pays bien
quelques mètres plus loin le ballon à
changer de forme et les activités se
pratiquent toujours en famille on est en
train de faire 28 août à comme tu ferais
dans le stade
si mon corps confirmant là on s'entraîne
on fait des coups francs des tirs des
matchs si on s'entraîne pas on pourra
perdre son niveau ce nouveau confinement
devrait durer au minimum pendant quatre
semaines
un confinement certes plus léger mais
décrété en raison d'une situation très
tendue en ile de france vous le voyez
sur ces derniers chiffres qui s'affiche
le taux d'occupation des lits en
réanimation ne cesse d'augmenter
s'établissant hier dimanche à 113% dans
la région elle est donnée de la
contamination reste très élevé également
dans les yvelines taux d'incidence à 342
c'est le nombre de nouveaux contaminé
rapporté à cent mille habitants
cinq cent sept personnes étaient
hospitalisées dans les yvelines le 21
mars au 19 mars derniers chiffres dont
nous disposons 1466 passion avait
succombé aux colis de 19 dans les
établissements de santé du département
dans le même temps la campagne de
vaccination se poursuit dans les
yvelines 96 1691 yvelines ont été primés
vaccinées dans le département soit
presque quinze mille injections
supplémentaires en une semaine 13
centres sont actifs et un maxi bus pour
appel 6-1 également les zones rurales
pour aller vacciner depuis samedi
dernier avec le nouveau confinement les
commerces dits non essentiels ont dû
fermer leurs portes mais cette fois ci
la liste des magasins autorisés à ouvrir
a été étendue précision et réactions
avec astrid bergère un nouveau
confinement pour 16 départements dans
les yvelines depuis samedi 19 mars les
commerces non essentiels ont baissé le
rideau pour les magasins présents en
dehors des centres commerciaux des
aménagements ont été prévus
on va rester ouverts ont cliqué une
collègue en avoir les informations donc
bon c'est un peu embêtant parce qu'on
sera pas ouvert avec les clients mais
bon
on pourra toujours à subir les phares
les réservations et surtout redonner les
commandes des clients quoi pour cette
commerçante qui a notamment perdu un
proche du coc vide ce confinement est
justifié employé dans une mercerie la
boutique reste ouverte non sans
précaution on va limiter le nombre de
personnes qui vont rentrer dans le
magasin de façon à ce que il ya au moins
deux ou trois personnes
si on est trois à servir une personne
pour chacun des autres personnes
attendront dehors une personne qui rend
qui sortira une personne qui rentrera
mais c'est une personne je veux dire ce
ne sera pas une personne et les enfants
c'est la personne toute seule du côté
des clients les avis sont partagés entre
lassitude et compréhension je fais de la
lecture je fais de la peinture je vais
chez les copines je fais de la
méditation je fais attention choses
comme ça je m'ennuie pas ils finissent
pas nous gaver sérieusement nous peut
plus rien faire nous empêche de vivre
sérieusement que ce soit les petits
commerçants comme les ouvriers faut dire
ce qui est beaucoup de pertes d'emploi à
cause de tout ça - et en aide ménagère
si je n'ai pas de travail je fais
comment si certains magasins ont dû
fermer des commerces dits essentiels ont
été ajoutés à la liste comme les
fleuristes ou les librairies on continue
à parler de ce sujet avec bernard cohen
hadad bonsoir bonsoir avec nous par
visioconférence merci d'être avec nous
est le président de la ces pme paris ile
de france et la confédération des
petites et moyennes entreprises
le gouvernement a été critiqué dès ce
week-end pour son manque de clarté
notamment sur la question des
attestations là avec les commerces qui
sont fermés d'autres qui peuvent rester
ouverts on a du mal aussi à s'y
retrouver
mais vous savez depuis le prêt d'un an
c'est très difficile pour nous aussi
entrepreneur petites et moyennes
entreprises de nous y retrouver mon
succès dont on enchaîne les confinements
les couvre-feux et paradoxalement la
situation n'est pas bonne la situation
sanitaire est mauvaise vous avez rappelé
tout à l'heure le taux d'incidence dans
les yvelines 342 en seine-saint-denis
les sept centres 1 513 vous rendez
compte un petit peu la difficulté
aujourd'hui l'épée de damoclès qui pèse
non seulement sur nos entrepreneurs sur
nos salariés sur les cons
la terre est ce que les commerçants eux
mêmes ont été perdus ces derniers jours
sur le fait de d'avoir l'autorisation de
rester ouverts ou non est ce que eux
aussi ont été perdus oui vous savez ces
annonces du jeudi c'est extrêmement mal
vécu par l'ensemble de nos entrepreneurs
et nos salariés on annonce souvent le
jeudi pour des dispositions qui seront
mises en place le samedi le décret
d'application on l'a reçu samedi
fort heureusement certains commerces ont
été ouverts grâce aux informations qui
ont pu faire monter à la à la présidente
de région mais aussi au préfet de région
c'était important pour nous convaincre
que soit ouvert les fleuristes les
chocolatiers mais aussi les coiffeurs
c'était extrêmement important de garder
ces lieux de 10 et puis c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on vous annonce des mesures le
jeudi effective le samedi vous n'avez
pas le temps de vous retrouver et c'est
beaucoup d'angoissé parce que on ne sait
pas encore s'il faut appliquer tel
protocole qu'il faut appliquer un autre
protocole et si tout simplement le stop
que vous avez acheté en début de semaine
vous pourrez le vendre en fin de semaine
mais en tout ce sont soixante mille
commerçants en ile de france qui devrait
être impacté par ces nouvelles mesures
tel est le sentiment qui règne on
imagine l'inquiétude pour justement les
commerces qui ne peuvent plus ouvrir
aujourd'hui
oui il ya un vrai désespoir vrai mal
être une vraie angoisse tu des
entrepreneurs une vraie angoisse aussi
des salariés
cette situation est difficile et vous
l'avez évoqué justement dans vos
reportages il y en a qui en ont un peu
marre à la fois il ya une grande
solidarité vis-à-vis des hôpitaux il ya
une grande solidarité vis-à-vis du
personnel soignant il ya aussi une
grande solidarité vis-à-vis des malades
ou de ceux qui dans nos familles ont
perdu un proche il faut pas oublier ce
virus est une vraie saloperie jeudi des
guillemets il faut avoir le courage de
le dire
et paradoxalement la vie économique doit
toujours retrouver ses droits parce que
derrière il ya des hommes et de femmes
qui ont besoin de travailler et puissent
aussi de sortir chez eux
vous savez peut-être pas beaucoup dans
les yvelines et pourtant dans les idées
niña il y à des zones en ile-de-france
où l'habitat social est extrêmement
concentré et on a besoin de se déplacer
sortir telle est la priorité aujourd'hui
ce qu'il faut d'ores et déjà travaillé
sur un plan de réouverture justement
pour ses commerces qui aujourd'hui sont
fermés pour nous il ya trois priorités
si vous me permettez la priorité c'est
de faire exploser
cette différenciation artificielle entre
commerces essentiel et commerces qui ne
sont pas entre activités utiles et
activités qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui
moi je ne comprends pas pourquoi on ne
peut pas vendre de l'habillement des
vêtements de la maroquinerie des
chaussures voire de l'ameublement et on
peut les trouver sur le web tout ça ce
n'est pas acceptable
il faut avoir le courage de le dire
ensuite je crois qu'il faut aussi que
l'on rappelle qu' il faut mettre en
place une politique extrêmement massive
de vaccination ça a été rappelé
également
il faut développer la vaccination y
compris auprès de notre public c'est à
dire nos salariés qui sont en première
ligne
on voyait tout à l'heure dans le
reportage un magasin de décoration et de
tissus quand vous voyez des clients
forcément le virus peut rentrer enfin et
ça nous semble aussi quelque chose de
fondamental développer le numérique les
aides au numérique ne sont pas assez
élevés c'est avec l'état mais 500 euros
la région à 1000 1500 euros il faut
renforcer ses aises numérique parce que
le développement du numérique dans nos
tpe pme qui nous permettra de faire plus
de péter travail il permettra aussi
d'avoir des vitrines en e-commerce et ça
ça nous aidera à limiter les dégâts en à
terme de perdre de clients perdent de
chalandise non justement sur les aides
le gouvernement s'est aussi de nouvelles
dispositions pour les obtenir désormais
une aide de 1500 euros pourraient être
débloqués pour les entreprises qui
accuse une perte de 20% de leur chiffre
d'affaires contre 50% auparavant
est ce que c'est un bon début fallait-il
aller plus loin peut-être débloquer de
nouvelles aides vous parlez du numérique
notamment
on l'avait demandé moi je l'avais
demandé dès le mois de janvier il
n'était pas acceptable que les
travailleurs non salariés les
indépendances ceux qui aujourd'hui et
non pas de salaire c'est à dire quand
vous n'êtes pas trop non salariés vous
fermez vous avez le droit à rien on
avait demandé à une baisse du taux
d'éligibilité du fonds de solidarité moi
je suis heureux donc de voir que le
gouvernement l'a entendu nous avions
fait remonter avec la ceppm nationale
les aussi avec la région ile-de-france
ce type de demande
nos entrepreneurs ne doivent pas rester
sur le carreau ils ont une double peine
l'appel de la fermeture la peine des
loyers qui tombe au sli vous savez parce
que même quand vous êtes fermé vous
dépaysera toyer et puis aussi la peine
si vous me le permettait d'avoir une
évasion
de leur clientèle parce qu'un certain
nombre de deux consommateurs aujourd'hui
ce se dirige vers les marketplace et les
gaffes à c'est-à-dire cette banque en
ligne qui nous cause beaucoup de
problèmes dans un contexte de crise
durable
alors cette période demain c'est aussi
la période des premiers remboursements
des pg e
ces prêts garantis par l'état les
entreprises pouvaient commencer les
remboursements des semaines mars où les
reporter d'un an et est ce que beaucoup
d'entreprises aujourd'hui sont dans
cette situation de devoir reporter
justement ce remboursement du pge le
problème de la dette et surtout des
prêts consentis par les entreprises est
un problème extrêmement crucial vous
savez que on estime alors c'est pour
toute la france qu'il ya entre 8 à 10%
des entreprises qui ont souscrit un pdg
eux qui ne pourront pas le rembourser ça
représente encore près 8 à 10 milliards
d'euros sur un plan de relance de 100
milliards ce n'est pas grand chose ceci
étant nous ce que nous demandons c'est
deux choses d'une part c'est la capacité
pour ces entreprises qui n'arrive pas
aujourd'hui à rembourser leur pg ou
qu'ils ne pourront pas rembourser y
compris les premières échéances c'est de
reporter à travers un p jeu consolider
ses échéances pendant dix ans c'est à
dire qu'on pourra payer non pas en cinq
ans mais en visant ça c'est la première
proposition de la cpmn une deuxième
proposition que nous avons fait nous
l'avons publié dans un journal du soir
qui s'appelle des échos le 5 6 février
nous demandons une effacement de la
dette pour les entreprises
d'ile-de-france qui ont un intérêt
stratégique et une utilité sociétale
j'espère que les entreprises petites
moyennes et plus grandes ne pourront pas
s'endetter lourdement et elles
risqueront tout simplement de mettre la
clé sous la porte ou voire d'être
achetés par des entreprises étrangères
et ça ne pouvons pas l'accepter
merci bernard cohen-hadad d'abord être
avec nous merci à vous bonjour à tous et
bon sens mais également et je rappelle
que vous êtes le président de la ces pme
paris ile de france la confédération des
petites et moyennes entreprises
toujours au chapitre économique la
quatrième édition des ambitieuses take
for good c'est un appel à projets lancé
par la ruche le réseau d'incubateurs est
dédié à l'innovation sociale il est
ouvert jusqu'au 24 mars aux femmes
entrepreneures à la clé un
accompagnement de neuf mois pour dix
lauréates représentation dans cette
interview express collectées par justine
braz et seulement 9% des entrepreneurs
dans les nouvelles technologies sont les
femmes et alors que 70% des femmes
pensent que l'entrepreneuriat est une
vraie solution intéressante par rapport
au salariat donc voilà c'est fait c'est
ce chiffre là qu'on a envie de changer
qui est pas normal être une femme
entrepreneur ou faire partie d'une
équipe dirigeante en tant que femme
avoir un projet innovant avoir un projet
impact et avoir déjà fait la preuve de
son concept il ya dix l'oréal qui vont
bénéficier d'un accompagnement sur neuf
mois avec des accompagnements collectif
donc en groupe des formations en terme
commercial
et puis en terme de terme de financement
c'est les deux gros sujet en fait de
cette accélération
c'est la première année en fait tout le
programme est ouvert sur vraiment toute
la france
du coup la rue de saint germain
participent à cette à ce programme d
ambitieuse de manière active donc à
cette année on serait ravis d'avoir
lauréate volonté dans notre communauté
dans l'actualité également ce procès qui
s'ouvre tribunal correctionnel de
versailles la direction d'ikea france
comparaît pour espionnage à l'échelle
industrielle la filiale du géant suédois
est accusé d'avoir recueilli pendant
plusieurs années des informations
confidentielles sur des salariés et des
candidats à l'embauché
l affaire a été révélée en 2012 par
mediapart et le canard enchaîné sur le
banc des accusés une quinzaine de
personnes dont deux anciens pdg et des
directeurs de magasin mais aussi des
fonctionnaires de police les peines
encourues vont jusqu'à dix ans de prison
ikea français poursuivent et également
tant que personne morale et risque trois
millions d'euros d'amendés procès
jusqu'au 2 avril à versailles ces images
impressionnantes à présent à
mantes-la-ville le gymnase aimé bergeal
a été entièrement ravagé par un incendie
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
une cinquantaine de pompiers a été
dépêché sur place pour circonscrire le
feu vers 4 heures du matin les origines
du sinistre sont pour l'heure ne sont
pour l'heure pas encore connu aucune
trace d'effraction n'aurait été constaté
sur place et les portes du bâtiment
situé le long de l'autoroute a13 étaient
fermés les enquêteurs sont à la
recherche d'éventuelles traces
d'hydrocarbures
le gymnase était utilisé par les
collégiens et des écoliers de la ville
ainsi que par plusieurs associations de
la commune du 22 au 27 mars c'est la 32e
édition de la semaine de la presse à
l'école l'objectif faire comprendre aux
élèves le fonctionnement des médias
à cette occasion deux journalistes célia
200 go et patrick jacques de dixmude
sont allés à la rencontre et d'élèves de
cm1 c'était à l'école anne turgot de
sartrouville regarder
[Musique]
cette classe de cm1 pratique la radio
depuis une semaine à l'occasion de la
semaine de la presse et de notre venue à
l'école élémentaire and turgot à
sartrouville cette vingtaine d'élèves
avaient préparé une émission sur le
métier de journaliste et nous a posé des
questions comment vous n'aimez ni les
changements mais cette année ce sont
trois classes de cm1 qui participent au
projet radio dans un premier temps on a
fait de l'interprétation de poésie pour
les familiariser avec toute la technique
et puis apprendre à parler au micro et
là maintenant on rentre vraiment dans
l'enseignement aux médias en maintenant
des pieds reportage comment fonctionne
une rédaction qu'est ce qu'un reportage
ou comment se construit un journal
autant de sujets développés avec trois
classes à l'ecoute les élèves ont appris
beaucoup
comment on faisait la radio comment et
effet la radio télévisée c'est à dire à
la télé comment là on l'a préparé
combien de temps devait durer une
chronique combien de temps dure et la
rédemption
j'ai appris c'est quoi tes marines et
des crues et messi et régna caméras
c'était vraiment découvrir inside le
métier de journaliste les différents
rôles que ce soit chroniqueur au
reporter vraiment vivre le quotidien des
journalistes
les 3000 de reportage c'est un processus
d'une journée avec effectivement le rôle
du chef de rédaction le monteur donc
tout ce qu'on ne voit pas à l'écran qui
est au combien important il était en
tout cas important pour nous de faire
partager à ses élèves de neuf ans notre
métier et de leur donner envie pourquoi
pas de devenir à leur tour journaliste
une petite précision concernant
l'incendié dont je vous parlais il ya un
instant à le gymnase aimé bergeal été
entièrement ravagé par un incendie dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche
contrairement à ce que je vous ai
annoncé tout à l'heure ce n'est pas à
mantes la jolie mais à mantes la ville
qui est situé ce gymnase et vous
rappeler également que les origines du
sinistre sont pour l'heure toujours
méconnu on termine ce journal avec un
peu de poésie le printemps des poètes se
termine le 27 mars le tout
de la programmation à saint quentin en
yvelines au micro de célia get on go
il a dû être mis en ligne ce qui est un
très simple et puis énormément mais
finalement l' avantage c'est que ça
permet de toucher un public plus large
est ce que des personnes qui n'habitent
pas à saint-quentin enfin qui sont
éloignés qui ne seraient pas venues peut
tout à fait voir toutes les rencontres
les spectacles en différé jusqu'au 30
juin
et puis j'ai ça m'a amené aussi à créer
une proposition nouvelle des podcasts
[Musique]
demain à 18 heures une rencontre avec
cécile oumhani romancière poète
voilà qui a vraiment un travail très
intéressant
on a tellement besoin de garder quand
même ce lien avec le public et puis de
soutenir les artistes parce que pour eux
bas on entend dans les nouvelles c'est
vraiment extrêmement compliqué ça permet
quand même de faire des choses
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec télé
[Musique]